we welcome you to cbs mornings and we're
going to begin with president biden
faces a very important test this morning
on a worldwide stage he's addressing the
u.n general assembly in a few hours from
now it's a very tricky time for the
president who faces very tough questions
from other world leaders about his
decisions on afghanistan and a wide
range of other issues nancy cordes is
outside the united nations headquarters
on the east side of manhattan with more
on the story nancy good morning to you
good morning gail the president arrived
last night and today he will deliver his
first speech to the u.n as president you
know he's been enjoying something of an
extended grace period on the world stage
but now he's suddenly facing some sticky
diplomatic challenges of his own making
president biden was greeted by the u.n
secretary general who zoomed past
pleasantries into tough talk telling
reporters that the relationship between
the u.s and china is completely
dysfunctional warning that it could lead
to a new cold war we need to
re-establish a functional relationship
between the two powers
at the same time france's foreign
minister was unloading on the white
house for secretly negotiating a
contract to provide australia with
nuclear-powered submarines negating a 66
billion dollar deal france cut with
australia years ago the diplomatic
tension is a turnabout for president
biden who earlier this summer was being
hailed by the french and other foreign
leaders as a welcome change of pace
everyone in that room today understood
the shared appreciation
quite frankly that america is back today
president biden will try to turn the
page calling for intensive diplomacy to
combat climate change and covet 19.
he'll be able to tout new u.s
international travel rules loosening
coveit restrictions starting in november
travelers from 33 countries will be
allowed to enter the u.s with proof of
vaccination and a negative covit test
british prime minister boris johnson who
will meet with mr biden later today
declared himself delighted
another big elephant in the room today
afghanistan we're told that when
president biden speaks this morning he
will vigorously defend his decision to
end the war there and he'll make the
case that it clears the way for the u.s
to work more closely with its allies to
tackle big problems that can't be solved
with military force nate
we'll have more on that later in the
show nancy thank you so much the